[Music]
in
you're doing it wrong news you're doing
it wrong
are you supposed to do it then that way
bend over
whoa okay no like push-ups right you
don't want to do something like this
bend it over you're not bent over [ __ ]
off
we get it you're strong submitted by
soft wood floors
soft wood floors that's a good idea
funny
so it's all balsa wood yeah it breaks
really easily yeah that's nice
it's the [ __ ] that you make a cork out
of because oh
oh my god that's an amazing floor
but imagine if your dog pees on it just
gets soaked into it
damn yeah i don't know all right well
that ended fast good point
a group of vegans have been accused of
cuddling pigs to
death while protesting vegans are so
nice
every time i met a vegan i felt like
they taught me a lot about
life and i really appreciate they're
really fun to hang with yeah
i really appreciate all their knowledge
and like their passion behind
wanting to control the world they're a
fun hang yeah
vegans have such an asinine like
reputation
that i i hope it changes you know what
though like
are you vegan i'm not vegan i just feel
like
anyone who is trying in any capacity
should be given like like good job like
even if it's like i still eat meat but
i no longer like eat five hamburgers a
day i eat four hamburgers
like per week or whatever it is right
like it's like if you're cutting down
you should be given a gold medal just
for cutting down and i think vegans have
made it very
hard for people to want to even try
because you get so
like ostracized perfectly vegan it's
that
evangelical type aspect of the [ __ ]
vegan community that crazy ass like
i'm gonna preach the word of veganism
anybody who goes too hard in anything is
just unfun for me yeah that's my whole
thing whether you're vegan or religious
or
you're just not bad it's like dude
you're annoying there's some like
bodybuilder or like powerlifter guys
that follow and that are super for
certain like the anti-vegan diet almost
like a carnivore diet
and they're pretty much talking [ __ ]
about carrots and like cucumbers and
stuff wow i'm like damn that's [ __ ]
crazy
pretty hard bro yeah i'm like i think
you're just as bad as the other dudes if
you're just going in on just you should
only eat me and you're like [ __ ] are the
carrots sad
because they're just getting bashed on i
heard i don't know fruits and vegetables
are happy
well i always say that one day we're
going to find out that like lettuce hat
can
feel and then it's going to get
interesting they did say plants can feel
yeah they did say that so when
lettuce they can communicate too they
can actually communicate and by the way
you know a lot of vegans don't like me
saying this but i will say it because i
enjoy debate
um the amount of woodland creatures and
like little small animals that get
killed
because you like salad more is pretty
high
yeah like by tractors and all the [ __ ]
that they you know they till land with
and stuff so it's not just like there's
no like no murder
zone no and there's actually a lot of
like farmers because they care about
their crops whether it's to grow tofu or
whatever
they're blasting all the [ __ ] toads
and turtles that are swimming around
eating their like soy product so they're
killing hell and animals just to farm
like a lot of these
vegan friendly foods exactly yeah unless
they're like living off the grid and
making their own food and growing their
own vegetables they're not
really doing these toads and turtles are
their [ __ ]
pests now so they kind of blast them
would you say different is that is one
worse than the other oh yeah are you
saying it's equal
no no no i'm not saying it's equal i'm
just saying there's no murder-free zone
for sure well i don't think vegans i
mean and i'm not talking about the
hardcore ones i don't think vegans think
that
i think all they're trying to do is just
like be ethical or for environmental
reasons or they're just trying to uh
kill like the lowest food or not kill
but consume the lowest
but what about the toads the dead toes
and the dead turtles i'm only talking
about the extreme ones who are like
you're a murder face because you eat
animals that's why lisa simpson is what
a level four vegan oh yeah
she doesn't eat anything that casts a
shadow and i think everyone should live
by that
i need to order cats it's so [ __ ]
funny i was thinking of going vegan
i'm a level five vegan i won't eat
anything that casts a shadow
wow eat i think that's probiotics that's
the joke
that's a joke there's nothing only air
yeah there's even water
even water well you just gotta eat
maustin because it's only in the shadow
so it doesn't have shadow
what the [ __ ] is monster moss that oh
moss
then you mean like austin massachusetts
mercury retrograde we can't
hear i kept miss hearing all day today
nobody heard it
smoking like my wife you guys heard it
she told me about mercury retrograde for
the past like [ __ ] five days
okay so what we're talking about here
pigs yes dead pigs
there were 200 vegans from the group
meet the victims and it's spilled meat
like the meat that we eat of course
um so they stormed a farm in the uk
in order to protest against pork but
they're saying the farm is saying
that they they ended up
suffocating what did they storm the
farms with they ended up squashing
one of the pigs what they
black friday trampled on them two of the
pigs
and then two other piglets had been
taken away
uh and then so they ended up
they just [ __ ] up okay this might be
really [ __ ] up but i think it's so
funny when people have the best of
intentions and then they [ __ ] it all up
for themselves yeah they're just
i think that's the funniest thing humans
let's just be humans are shitty
true it's like when you when you see uh
environmentalists they go out and they
do
some big protests somewhere to be like
stop all delivering and [ __ ] and then
they they
when you view the photos of the next day
of people cleaning this [ __ ] up like the
janitor's cleaning up
it's like crazy there's just [ __ ]
from the bottles everywhere
yeah exactly like papers everywhere and
[ __ ] so [ __ ] they're like protesters
everyone's a hypocrite that's like you
said like humans are
all terrible my brother hugged the [ __ ]
out of a [ __ ] bunny and killed it
when he was a kid he landed he loved the
[ __ ] out of that bunny
no who's lenny from from mice and men
of my semen he was kind of not
he's like he was low but he was strong
dude yeah what would trigger
your father i'm like i thought he was
really smart no i think he's like uh
he's a
he's supposed to be like a down syndrome
kid or something i think it's never
said it's never said but it's just but
then aren't down syndrome people like
strong as hell he definitely has the
strength factor right yeah i don't know
nikki um has not been a she's not a
vegan but she's definitely done like
she doesn't like eating animals very
much yeah uh and she has show
she's taught me that pigs are pretty
smart they're really smart yeah people
have them as pets and that's one of her
protests about eating
that's why she doesn't want to eat like
pig but it's delicious
i know it's very good and then so and
that's my thing is like i get that
they're really smart and that they have
emotional
responses to things and they even like
love each other yeah
and the more you eat the more emotional
you get right but they're not smart
enough to escape yet
and begin a movement and i think once
they are then i'll be on their side i'll
stop eating them if
they learn how to talk if they evolve
that much
i'm gonna learn how to make them show
they talk with their eyes
they look at you and they're like help
me and they blink twice at you
i see them at the at the um state fair i
want to pet them
and then i get hungry and i go walk over
to the area where they're serving
hot dogs yeah only the piglets are cute
like they're cute i like the big guys
too those i guess are called
i like the big old picks they're cute
big old sounds the sals people look like
walmart ladies
they do the fat ones they do that hang
out at walmart
and they're so fat that it looks like
they're when they wear like
sandals and stuff it looks like a
sausage in a sandal pigs look like my
grandpa's old head where it's just scalp
and then a bunch a couple stringy hairs
going yeah
it looks like a grandma with moles on it
yeah so this is the group
meet the victim
so they're saying that they like picked
up some piglets and then
so they broke into a farm they would
pick them up and then like put them in
the wrong place
oh come on you morons why would they
show they're crying like why would they
take pictures of their own climbing
because it's part of their protest like
it was part of them like
bringing awareness to how poorly they're
being held
yeah that doesn't look like a [ __ ] up
farm though
yeah well there's this other one i'm not
going to show it to you but
i mean this is a pretty tiny pen for
sure they're breaking into all these
beverly hills farms
like these big ones here um like the pig
is literally
trapped and it can't even turn around
because they're too fat
they can't move well the pens are too
they're pen
it's literally like this oh like
yeah yeah that's wrong i mean i think
it's like it
people come from the with the best
intentions right and i think
we as people of this generation have
seen enough
uh chatter on twitter and whatnot and
seen enough documentaries to understand
that the meat packing industry is
it's terrible it is really bad and i
think we all know that
and i think making small strides like in
our personal lives does a lot
i i think that i don't know like
again like just because you have a big
group of people
talking about it doesn't mean that it's
going to always work
and you know it's like i think that you
have to live by example and this was
clearly a bad example they didn't do
they didn't thoroughly think
think it through i think that's what it
is yeah and i think people should lead
through just positivity and like through
by example and compassion because that's
what they're all about
yeah so if you can make a change
positively and show everyone like how
dope it is like
i think that's better than trying to
bash another group because it'd be like
for example
like me and joe used to preach pursue
your passions a lot
right and then i don't believe it so we
would try we would like show like hey
like when you pursue your passions like
you're really
passionate about all the things that
you're doing and you feel really
rewarding but we didn't go
to like a bunch of like skyscrapers and
started screaming your job [ __ ] sucks
everyone [ __ ] sucks in here like it's
a good idea
like that would be that that might wake
them up start pursuing your passion
backfire so hard because they're like
wait these guys that are pursuing their
so like every year like a bunch of
buddhists will go to the pet store and
they'll buy
fish and then they'll release it into
the ponds here right but what they do is
they
introduce invasive species into the
[ __ ] water
and they destroy the ecosystem but they
think they're doing something awesome by
like
you know releasing these uh piranhas
piranhas or snakeheads or i don't know
they they get some
fish they don't even know what they are
they don't do the research but they're
like we're gonna release these
these fish and we're gonna let them back
into the ecosystem
and it's like man you just [ __ ] up
the world doing that right
so that's that's i see it as the same
thing it's like you're not thinking
things through
you don't even do your research you have
good intentions and a great heart
but you're actually doing way more
damage it's like the people who pick up
the little dolphin to take a picture
with it
yeah they have such good intentions
they just want to hug it and love it
they love it they like a dolphin it's
definitely like a measurement of like
good intention versus selfish like me
right because it's like if you if the
only reason why you're doing something
like good or charitable is because it's
to feed a selfish need then that's
something where you just gotta
take a step back yep
for sure you can always go too hard no
and then vegans are watching this right
now and you're like i don't see you
against me in front of me or whatever
no i it's the extreme ones well yeah i
am but no it's the extremes it's like
conspiracy [ __ ]
i love conspiracy [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
fun but sometimes
you can take it too far like for example
you know i think all the jfk shit's
pretty legit and dope
but then recently like
someone who i think is taking things a
little too far alex jones right
so he he called me out for
making the thing he knows you so he well
he didn't call me up my name but he
called me out for
um he called up about us who made the
thinning too
because he's saying that we're it's
called the thinning new world order and
we're trying to indoctrinate kids to
make them ready for population control
and i'm
like dude if you knew me and michael
gallagher who wrote this movie
you'd know that a couple [ __ ] idiots
wrote this in a basement
like it's not there was no like meeting
with the
illuminati new world order [ __ ] that's a
huge compliment
it is it's pretty cool to think that
what have you not told us
what was that what have you not told
them right exactly but that's what i'm
saying where you can you can just
where it's you copy paste that attitude
into everything
so now everything that you see is part
of this conspiracy thing or this
like the con construct in your mind of
how much the world sucks like
like vegan gotta be everything that i do
in my life like it just
gets to be too much and you become
[Music]
annoying
[Music]
you